En este video vamos a hablar sobre los gases
ideales y cómo podemos describir lo que pasa con
ellos, así que la primera pregunta que podríamos
hacer es ¿qué es un gas ideal? Y en realidad la
respuesta es una construcción un poco teórica que
nos ayuda a describir lo que pasa en el mundo de
los gases, o al menos se acerca a lo que pasa en
ese mundo. Así que imaginamos que en un gas ideal
sus partículas individuales no interactúan, las
partículas no interactúan. Y obviamente sabemos
que eso en general no es cierto, generalmente
hay algunas fuerzas intermoleculares ligeras,
a medida que las partículas se acercan o cuando
pasan una al lado de la otra o si chocan entre
sí. Pero por el bien de lo que vamos a estudiar
en este video supondremos que no interactúan,
y también supondremos que las partículas no tienen
volumen, no tienen volumen. Ahora sabemos que
eso no es exactamente cierto, que las moléculas
individuales, por supuesto, tienen volumen. Pero
esta es una suposición razonable porque en general
podría representar una fracción infinitamente
pequeña del volumen total del espacio en el que
están rebotando. Y éstas son las dos suposiciones
que hacemos cuando hablamos de gases ideales, por
eso usamos la palabra "ideal". En futuros videos
hablaremos sobre comportamientos no ideales; pero
esto nos permite hacer algunas simplificaciones
que se aproximan a muchas cosas en el mundo.
Así que pensemos cómo podemos describir los
gases ideales. Podemos pensar en el volumen del
contenedor en el que se encuentran. Podríamos
imaginar la presión que ejercerían, digamos, en el
interior del contenedor, así es como lo visualizo;
aunque esa presión sería la misma en cualquier
punto dentro del contenedor. Podemos pensar en
la temperatura, y queremos hacerlo en escala
absoluta, de modo que generalmente medimos la
temperatura en Kelvin. Y también podríamos pensar
en la cantidad de gas que tenemos, podemos medirlo
en términos de número de moles, eso es lo
que representa esta n minúscula. Entonces
pensemos cómo relacionar entre sí estas cuatro
cosas. Pongamos siempre el volumen en el lado
izquierdo. ¿Cómo se relaciona el volumen con la
presión? Bueno, lo que me imagino es que si tengo
un globo como este, si tengo algo de gas en el
globo y trato de disminuir el volumen haciéndolo
más pequeño sin dejar salir ningún otro aire
y sin cambiar la temperatura, así que no estoy
cambiando T ni n, ¿qué va a pasar con la presión?
Bueno este gas va a ejercer más y más fuerza por
pulgada cuadrada o por área cuadrada, cada vez
me va a costar más apretar este globo, así que,
a medida que el volumen disminuye, la presión
aumenta; de igual manera, si tuviera que agrandar
el contenedor sin cambiar la temperatura ni la
cantidad de moles que tengo dentro del contenedor,
la presión va a disminuir. Parece que el volumen
y la presión se mueven inversamente entre sí,
entonces, lo que podríamos decir es que el volumen
es proporcional a 1 sobre la presión, el inverso
de la presión, o podríamos decir que la presión
es proporcional al inverso del volumen. Esto sólo
significa proporcional a, lo que significa que el
volumen sería igual a una constante dividida entre
la presión en este caso. Ahora, ¿cómo se relaciona
el volumen con la temperatura? Bueno, si empezamos
con el ejemplo del globo -y podrías hacer la
prueba si tienes dudas-, si tomamos un globo y
lo inflamos a temperatura ambiente y lo ponemos
en el congelador, se va a encoger. Y podríamos
preguntarnos ¿por qué se está encogiendo? Bueno,
podemos imaginar que las partículas dentro del
globo son un poco menos vigorosas en ese punto y
tienen energías cinéticas individuales más bajas,
y para que puedan ejercer la misma presión para
compensar la presión atmosférica del exterior, van
a tener un volumen menor, entonces podríamos decir
que el volumen es proporcional a la temperatura.
Ahora, ¿cómo se compara el volumen con el número
de moles? Bueno, piénsalo: si soplamos aire en un
globo, estamos poniendo más moles en ese globo,
y si mantenemos la presión y la temperatura
constante, vamos a aumentar el volumen, así que
el volumen es proporcional al número de moles. Si
tuviéramos que sacar aire, también va a disminuir
el volumen manteniendo constante la presión y
la temperatura. Entonces podemos usar estas tres
relaciones: la primera en realidad se conoce como
Ley de Boyle, esta es la Ley de Charles y esta
es la Ley de Avogadro. Pero podemos combinarlas
para darnos cuenta de que el volumen va a ser
proporcional al número de moles por la temperatura
entre la presión. Otra forma de decirlo es que
ese volumen va a ser igual a alguna constante;
de eso trata la proporcionalidad, va a ser igual
a alguna constante que llamaremos R por todo esto:
RnT / P. U otra forma de pensarlo es que podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por P. ¿Y qué obtendremos?
Obtendremos P por V -esto podría ser familiar
para algunos de ustedes-, cambiaré el orden aquí,
es igual a n, que es el número de moles, por
alguna constante R por T. Nuestra temperatura
medida en Kelvin. Esta relación que tenemos
aquí PV = nRT. Es una de las cosas más útiles
en Química y se conoce como la Ley de los gases
ideales. En futuros videos vamos a aplicarla una
y otra vez para ver lo útil que es. Ahora, tal
vez se estén preguntando ¿qué es esta constante?
Se conoce como Constante de los gases ideales,
y puedes investigarlo, pero dependerá de las
unidades que se usen para la presión, volumen y
temperatura. Eso lo veremos en videos futuros.